scomping droids an actor's Redemption
Darth Vader cosplay and more it's not a
trap just all the Easter eggs you missed
in the Mandalorian season 3. warning
spoilers ahead
in the time since the book of Boba Fett
dingarin seems to have become much more
comfortable flying his new Starfighter
the rebuilt N1 famous for being the
Baseline ship of the Nabu Royal Fleet is
loaded with Nifty gadgets and add-ons
but it also comes packed with plenty of
winks and nods to its debut appearance
in The Phantom Menace when din swoops in
to save the mandalorians from the giant
monster in season 3 episode 1. he kills
the Beast with proton torpedoes these
iconic weapons go all the way back to
the original Death Star run of course
but they're also used by Anakin to
destroy the trade federation's droid
control ship in The Phantom Menace brief
shots of the ship's interior reveal the
same Sleek controls and readouts seen in
the prior film and of course when din is
attacked by Pirates later in the same
episode he evades them by spinning hey
that's a good trick
yeah
foreign
s in the first episode of season three
comes during a hyperspace Voyage from
his bubble cockpit in the new N1 grogu
has a 360 degree view of hyperspace as
they travel to navarrogo notices some
looming shadowy shapes just out of focus
beyond the ship if you've seen Star Wars
Rebels you'll recognize these strange
figures instantly known as the pergil
these giant space whales can travel
through hyperspace naturally Legends
shared by Harris and Doula in Rebels
suggests that other species first
developed hyperspace travel to emulate
the pergil's abilities we also know from
Rebels that the creatures can be
connected via the force perhaps that's
why grogu is able to sense them so
profoundly while the pergil aren't
directly discussed in the apostates
their appearance seems like a clear
setup for later in the season or for the
upcoming Ahsoka series during her Cameo
appearance in the Mandalorian season 2
Ahsoka reveal feels that she's hunting
Grand Admiral thrawn who was last seen
whisked Away by a pergil in the rebels
finale and since Ezra's already been
confirmed to appear in the upcoming
series it's safe to assume that the
pergil will return
under the rule of high magistrate grief
carga the once Backwater planet of
Navarro has transformed into a thriving
trade Hub the automated message that
plays as din lands even calls it the gem
of the outer rim grief says that it's
becoming a major stop along the heavily
traveled hidian way that might explain
why there are so many different sorts of
aliens and Droids on the planet now many
of which should look familiar to Star
Wars fans there are mon calamari Corin
and even a cooked Droid of the same
basic style seen in Attack of the Clones
there are also a few familiar faces from
Jabba the Hutt's Tatooine Palace an EV
series supervisor Droid and a whole tree
filled with kawakian monkeys of course
the esteemed salacious beecrum himself
Jabba's kawakian pet is nowhere to be
found since he died along with Jabba in
Return of the Jedi one face you might
expect to see on Navarro is mentioned
only a name however Kara Dune the former
Rebel Shock Trooper played by Gina
Carano Carano was famously fired from
the Mandalorian after a series of tweets
comparing being a republican to the
Holocaust criticizing safe masking
policies during the covid-19 pandemic
and mocking the lgbtq plus Community
when grief tells din he needs a marshall
the Mandalorian asks what happened to
Cara what about Marshall Doom
after she brought in moff Gideon she was
recruited by Special Forces
tell the Dave
full Star Wars project
looking for weak way Pirates is a start
a group of the infamous racketeers shows
up on Navarro in the apostate and
immediately starts causing trouble to be
fair not every pirate in the gang is
weak way the spiky-headed race most
famous for giving us the inexplicable
Hondo onaka in Clone Wars and Rebels
other races are represented as well
including what appears to be a new
live-action
transharga do away with the crooks
easily enough but that's not the end of
them the encounter runs denafowl of
gorion Shard a self-proclaimed pirate
king who later battles the Mandalorian
in space Shard himself is not weak way
and seems like a sad substitute for good
old Hondo but he does bear a strange
resemblance to Davey Jones of Pirates of
the Caribbean Fame to complete his
mission of redemption and journey back
to Mandalore then decides that he needs
a Droid unfortunately din's traumatic
childhood during the Clone Wars has left
him with some major Droid trust issues
the only one he wants to work with is
ig-11 inconveniently is dead in trying
to repair the Droid then accidentally
triggers ig-11's old programming
prompting him to lash out and attack
rogu of course the Droid doesn't have
any legs so he has to crawl slowly
across the floor this seems like a
direct reference to the end of The
Terminator in which the titular
mechanoid assassin continues its Pursuit
after having its legs blown off ig-11
even States his intent to terminate the
asset surely that's not a coincidental
choice of words when it becomes clear to
din that he can't fix ig-11 on his own
he takes him to The Experts and zelen
droidsmiths that's right the same
species and profession as the rise of
Skywalker or breakout star Bobby Frick
while Babu himself doesn't appear to be
present the and Zealand we do meet have
the same charm and no-nonsense attitude
Babu has become quite the fan favorite
since his debut in the 2019 film so it's
fun to see the anselens return and also
to learn that the whole race is thought
of as the best droidsmiths in the galaxy
is this a cultural tradition or are the
enzelans just naturally gifted at
working with sentient machines these
great mysteries of Babu Fricks people
remain but with luck we'll learn more
about this mysterious alien race at the
end of season 3 episode 1 DIN and Grogan
travel to kalibala to meet with Boca tan
Crees he asks to join her mission to
retake Mandalore but she responds that
the faction she built abandoned her
after she failed to win the darksaber
since din is the one who now holds the
weapon she clearly resents him but she
seems to resent her people's
superstitious ways even more she even
says wave that thing around and they'll
do whatever you say it's hard not to
take this line as a reference to
mandalore's tragic history Bo katan's
sister such as sateen Crees was killed
by the darksaber when it was wielded by
Darth Maul during the Clone Wars a
faction of mandalorians followed Maul
afterwards simply because he had won the
blade in combat allowing him to rule the
planet from the Shadows Bo Katan helped
Ahsoka Tano and her Republic forces oust
the villain in the Clone Wars season
seven but that didn't end her or the
planet's troubles Bo Katan even partly
blames din's old plan for mandalore's
decline if you've watched the Clone Wars
and Rebels you know bocatan's pain she
watched her Planet be torn apart by
radicals terrorists separatists clones
and Imperial occupiers before finally
seeing it burned to nothing sitting on
the throne her sister must have sat on
decades prior bocatan looks like she's
finally fed up with it all
you might think tatooine's Barren
landscape wouldn't generate much festive
energy but that's far from the truth in
addition to General Cantina Hangin and
the thrill of frequent shootouts the
desert planet has at least one major
holiday bunta Eve when din jarin visits
mechanic palimoto in chapter 18 the
holiday is nigh and viewers see her
complaining to a client as part of a
scam of course about having to work on
bunta Eve this isn't the first time the
holiday is mentioned in Star Wars Canon
the pod racing event won by Anakin in
The Phantom Menace is called the bunta
eve classic so it has long been known as
a big day or denizens of Tatooine
According to some Star Wars
encyclopedias and Source books the
holiday celebrates a Hut named bunta who
supposedly achieved godhood according to
Pele it's mostly an excuse for drinking
and carousing in the Cantinas
reunite with pelimoto in the minds of
Mandalore frogu is so happy he literally
jumps for Joy the fourth slip he does is
a nice little nod to Yoda's own
dexterous fighting style and pelly
responds with a deep cut reference
taught you how to LEAP like a Lerman huh
the Lerman are small lemur-like
creatures native to the planet megito
they debuted in a season one episode of
Star Wars the Clone Wars the episode
Jedi crash sees three Jedi Anakin
Skywalker Ahsoka Tano and Ayla Sakura
crash on the planet maradon Anakin is
severely injured so Ahsoka and Ayla
enlist help from a group of local
lermans led by the strict pacifist tiwat
cough this faction departed their home
system and colonized maradon to escape
the war while certainly not a central
species in the grand Star Wars Mythos
the Mandalorian season 3 shows that they
haven't been forgotten
then jarin gains a surprising new ally
in season three Astro Metroid r5d4 the
Droid first appeared in the series in
season two but he takes on a much more
significant role in season 3 as din's
official companion this is indeed the
same r5d4 who debuted in A New Hope and
the Mandalorian adds some interesting
details to his canonical story R5 is
most famous for nearly becoming a
primary Droid in the series however it
had a bad motivator while Luke Skywalker
and Owen Lars were in the process of
buying him from the Jawas instead R2D2
went on to help save the day and become
a galactic hero what you might not know
is that R5 blew his motivator on purpose
to ensure r2's mission was a success in
the short story the red one featured in
the collection from a certain point of
view it's revealed that R2 tried to
sabotage R5 the night before the sale R5
woke up and noticed the attack prompting
R2 to explain that the fate of the
Galaxy depended on him escaping the
Jawas in a selfless move R5 agreed to
sabotage himself pelimoto says that R5
went on to serve in the Rebellion after
his encounter with R2 which has been
alluded to before
after two full seasons and some bonus
Adventures DIN jarin and grogu finally
journeyed to Mandalore in chapter 18.
there's a nice scene before they land
that has stin pointing out various
features of the system including the
moon where he grew up Concordia while
the two don't go there in the episode
Star Wars the Clone Wars visits
Concordia multiple times most notably
Concordia is the home of Death Watch
during the Clone Wars the Rogue faction
believed that Duchess sateen creases
pacifist government would destroy what
defined Mandalore so they schemed and
prepared in secret waiting for the right
moment to strike since the children of
the watch the hyperzealous group to
which Den belongs spawned from Death
Watch later in the Star Wars timeline it
makes perfect sense that he would have
grown up there Bo Katan also spent a lot
of time on Concordia as one of death
watch's Chief lieutenants it's
interesting to see how much she despises
the group now given that she helps lead
so many of its attacks on Mandalore
during the Clone Wars
din's journey to Mandalore ultimately
leads him to the ruins of sundari the
planet's old capital city The Living
Waters he must bathe in to earn
Redemption is beneath the city and the
old best car Minds specifically Boca tan
tells him that the mines lay beneath the
city's Civic Center while this
particular location isn't mentioned in
the Clone Wars the Animated Series does
spend quite a bit of time in sundari as
the seat of Duchess sateen creases brief
pacifist rule the city is visited
frequently by the likes of Ahsoka Tano
and Obi-Wan Kenobi Death Watch first
enters the story by bombing sundari's
peace Park which could be close to the
Civic Center a lot of time is also spent
in the sundari Royal Palace where Maul
kills the team and later duels Ahsoka
what might be difficult to discern in
the Mandalorian without knowledge of the
Clone Wars is that sundari was once a
fully enclosed Dome City as were most
Mandalorian settlements at the time
after rescuing Mando from The Perils of
mandalore's Minds in the episode Bo
Katan speaks briefly about her family
history she mentions her own brief rule
of the planet which took place in the
immediate aftermath of the Clone Wars
before she was ousted by the Empire she
also discusses her father he was a great
man
he died defending Mandalore
though bocatan and her sister sateen
have been key figures in Star Wars for
years very little is known about the
rest of their family history in the past
Star Wars books have identified their
father as duke Adonai creese who is said
to have been a strong leader but not
much else has ever been revealed
the ending of the Mandalorian chapter 18
contains a huge Revelation as he
attempts to cleanse himself in the
Living Waters dinjarin plummets deep
down Into the Depths bocatan leaps in to
save him but on their way back up they
see an impossible sight a living
mythosaur thought to have been extinct
for Generations the mythosaur is known
best not for its actual status as a
massive deadly creature but for becoming
the logo of the mandalorians the
mythosaurus skull sigil can be seen
across the franchise referencing the
mandalorians including in the armorers
various Workshops the symbol first
appeared and The Empire Strikes Back as
a decoration on Boba Fett's armor and
for many years it was Associated more
with bounty hunters in general than with
mandalorians in the new Canon however
the symbol has been directly tied to
Mandalorian culture bocatan goes into
that history a bit in the episode when
she reads a plaque mounted on a wall of
the mine it explains how the original
Mandalore supposedly killed a mythosaur
in the Living Waters ancient
mandalorians are purported to have
ridden the creatures into battle more
intriguing is that the series has
previously planted seeds of a prophecy
concerning the mythosaur in the book of
Boba Fett the armorer reveals a prophecy
to him the songs of eon's past foretold
of the mythosaur rising up to Herald a
new age of Mandalore now it seems only a
matter of time before he rides this new
one into battle darksaber in hand
at the beginning of chapter 19 the
convert DIN and bocatan exchange in an
exciting dogfight with some Thai
interceptors an advanced Thai model
designed for ship to ship combat Thai
interceptors first appeared in Star Wars
Return of the Jedi during the Battle of
Endor since then they've become a staple
of Star Wars video games and other
ancillary stories probably just because
they look so dang cool after taking down
the first deployment of Thai
interceptors with din bocatan is forced
to watch as three Thai bombers destroy
her family's ancestral home first
introduced in The Empire Strikes Back
Thai bombers are the same kind of ship
that bombed Mandalore to Oblivion in the
Great Purge which makes this moment hit
all the harder if you've played video
game series like Star Wars Battlefront
or the Star Wars Rogue Squadron series
one particular line during this dogfight
May Stand Out interceptors are a lot
tougher than Tie fighters historically
tight interceptors have been portrayed
as the Empire's flimsiest model in video
games sacrificing armor for Speed still
according to din they're Superior in
every way
during the space battle that opens the
convert bocatan pulls off what looks
like a Koya Grand turn to surprise a
pursuer cutting her engines and spinning
on a dime to line up a shot din does
something similar during a vertical
maneuver flying straight into the sky
before cutting his engines and flipping
180 degrees for a diving Attack okoya
Grand turn is a high-skilled star wars
flying technique first mentioned by name
in heir to the Empire a Star Wars
Legends novel released in 1991 that also
introduced fans to Grand Admiral thrawn
the second wave of Fighters coming after
our heroes is even larger than the first
prompting Bo to question how an imperial
warlord could have so many at his
disposal it's pretty clear that this
line is setting up some even bigger
future battles possibly even the return
of thrawn
during the dogfight with the Thai
interceptors din drops a couple of stray
lines that sound like direct references
to the Rogue Squadron video games thanks
for the backup two more to go in the
second game in the series 2001's Rogue
Squadron 2 Rogue leader most levels
involve you taking out waves of enemy
Fighters your wingmates will call out
when you're close to the end two more to
go while din's dialogue is generic
enough that it could just be coincidence
it feels like an homage Rogue leader is
a beloved classic and the battle on
kalavala is structured just like one of
its levels with multiple stages ship
changes and waves of enemy Fighters plus
it wouldn't be the first time that the
modern Star Wars Canon has referenced
older video games from Knights of the
Old Republic character Darth Revan being
mentioned in the rise of Skywalker so
the clone commandos from Republic
Commando popping up in the bad batch the
franchise loves to pay tribute to its
gaming past
most of the convert takes place on
Coruscant and follows Dr Pershing as he
tries to acclimate to life in the new
Republic we first see him giving a
speech about how the amnesty program for
former Imperials has helped him it's an
interesting scene that takes place in a
familiar building the red carpeted
theater where Pershing gives his talk is
the same place where she's Palpatine
once took Anakin Skywalker to the Opera
in Revenge of the Sith we see a similar
exterior shot of the orblight venue
officially known as the Galaxy's opera
house using the same venue here is a
nice touch as it demonstrates just how
little has actually changed for the
wealthy residents of Coruscant Empire
rebels new Republic I can't keep track
on the taxi ride home from giving his
speech at the Galaxy's Opera House Dr
Pershing gets some travel tips from his
Droid driver who mentions the Sky Dome
Botanical Gardens and the holographic
Museum of extinct animals at the latter
the Droid recommends checking out the
montebag of malistair which was
previously mentioned in a 2003 Star Wars
RPG Source book The Sky Dome meanwhile
previously appeared in Legends novels
like Star Wars Jedi search and Republic
Commando True Colors even the specific
attraction the Droid names there the
mices blossoms is a reference from an
old video game the plant is native to
The Wookie Homeworld of Kashif and
appeared there in the now defunct MMO
video game Star Wars Galaxies the mices
blossoms on Coruscant can also be read
as a nod to the famous cherry blossoms
in Washington DC both are beautiful
foreign flowers brought to spruce up a
capital city
ever wondered what days of the week are
called in the Star Wars Universe if
you're a real fanatic you might already
know but now thanks to the Mandalorian
even casual fans can look forward to
Tong's day and Bindu day like true
Galactic citizens Bindu day and Tong's
day both mentioned in the convert belong
to the galactic standard calendar the
common system based on coruscant's own
rotations in the Legends timeline the
calendar had a five-day week that
included those two days
of course due to every planet having its
own unique size rotational patterns and
cultural history the supposedly standard
calendar isn't quite as ubiquitous as
the denizens of Coruscant likely think
in the episode it seems safe to deduce
that it's not everyone's favorite day
given the context in which Elia Kane
says thongs days am I right
the old Legends calendar had Tong's day
in the middle of the week but it's
unclear if that's still the case
a galaxy-wide civil war that lasts for
decades leaves a pretty heavy footprint
of weapons ships and gear the convert
spends a lot of time exploring this idea
Dr pershing's new job under the new
Republic's amnesty program involves
cataloging Imperial gear most of which
is set to be destroyed we later see
massive shipyards filled with
decommissioned Star Destroyers just
sitting in the middle of Coruscant while
the Imperial gear is getting trashed old
Rebel Equipment is apparently still
worth using for instance the guards who
arrest Pershing at the end of the
convert wear the same bulbous helmets
that the rebel soldiers wear in A New
Hope however even some of the rebels old
gear is apparently headed for the scrap
Heap as Pershing supervisors inform him
that the alliance Fleet is also getting
decommissioned
there is perhaps no Star Wars line more
heavily memed or spoofed than this one
the iconic declaration uttered by
Admiral Akbar in Return of the Jedi is
as goofy as it is beloved and is so
famous that even Star Wars itself can't
seem to help but pay homage to it in the
convert after being arrested by New
Republic soldiers Dr Pershing is
strapped into a frightening device that
he calls a mind flayer administering the
treatment is a mon calamari the same
amphibious race as Akbar so pershing's
choice of words in this moment is a nice
bit of levity in a pretty Bleak episode
it was a trap season 3 episode 4 the
foundling opens on a training day for
din and grogu's covert foundlings and
others are shown training in various
forms of combat and weaponry many of
which have become synonymous with the
Warriors of Mandalore rogu himself
engages in a duel with the darts used by
DIN and Jango Fett among others we also
see the famous wrist mounted
flamethrowers Rockets being launched and
a whole lot of knife fighting there's
never been any doubt that din's covert
takes the way very seriously but it's
rewarding to see its members all
practicing so rigorously together in a
way the scene is the closest we've
gotten in the show to the mandalorians
of the old Star Wars Legends timeline
where there was never a pacifist era or
a death watch there was simply a race of
hardened Warriors who lived by a Creed
and longed to fight the foundling makes
a specific reference to death watch as
well as when the armorer Tells Paz visla
to take the shriekhawk training team on
a mission to rescue Ragnar a dangerous
creature native to Mandalore the shrie
was the symbol of Clan visla during
the Clone Wars when previsla ruled Death
Watch given the nature of the creature
that kidnaps Ragnar which bocatan calls
a raptor the team name seems appropriate
hitting grogu against a human child in a
combat challenge might seem cruel and
ill-considerate at first and yet the
little guy makes his dad proud then pits
grogu against Ragnar has vizsla's son in
a game of darts after taking two direct
shots to the chest grogu listens to
din's urgings and uses his Force powers
to secure a victory it's a triumphant
moment for the little guy and one that
evokes both Yoda and Luke Skywalker Yoda
famously used his small size and Agility
to disorient opponents flipping all
around and attacking from different
angles however Luke also uses the
somersault move quite a bit in the
original trilogy he modeled the
technique for grogu during their brief
time training together during the events
of the book Boba Fett clearly the
foundling was paying attention
after the Raptor kidnaps Ragnar in the
foundling bocatan chases the creature to
its nest and returns with the
coordinates she compares the area to the
peaks of Kyra Moritz where she
apparently trained in her youth these
are no higher than the peaks of
caramurid this is a deep cut reference
to the Legends timeline
specifically it's a call back to Karen
Travis's Republic Commando novels first
introduced in Republic Commando True
Colors Cairo morat was a settlement on
Mandalore composed of Renegades and
outcasts during and immediately after
the Clone Wars it became a Bastion for
clones who abandoned the Army as their
Jango Fett DNA effectively made the
mandalorians reintroducing Kyra Moret
into the Canon is a fun detail for those
who've read the books but of course it
probably still doesn't exist in the same
way it used to the geography of
Mandalore itself has changed a lot in
the current Canon from what it was in
Legends and the lore surrounding clone
deserters has also changed
after two and a half seasons of mystery
season 3's fourth episode finally shows
how grogu escaped the Jedi Temple during
Order 66 while several Jedi sacrificed
themselves in order to get him to safety
it's Master Keller and Beck who guards
him most of the way if you don't have
kids who also love Star Wars you might
not know that kelleran has been a part
of the Star Wars Universe for years
the character debuted in the online Star
Wars children's game show Jedi Temple
challenge in which he acts as the host
more importantly both the game show and
Mandalorian versions of teleran are
played by Ahmed best the same actor who
brought Jar Jar Binks to life in the
prequel trilogy it's great to see best
get to do some real lightsaber action
even if his purple blade from the show
is replaced with a green one at one
point Keller and pixel blue saber from
one of his Fallen comrades and fights
with both showing why he earned the
nickname the sabered hand
after an extended Airborne chase the
mandalorians managed to save Ragnar from
the Raptor that captures him a beast
that bears a striking resemblance to the
pterosaurs seen elsewhere in Star Wars
Legends rescuing Ragnar doesn't defeat
the Beast though for that task the
mandalorians enlist the help of the
giant alligator creature from Season 3
Episode 1. din breaks Ragnar free and
then knocks the Raptor down into the
water after inhibiting one of its wings
once down it's quickly gobbled up by the
much larger amphibian this feels like a
reference to the First Act of The
Phantom Menace In which Obi-Wan Qui-Gon
and jar jar are chased through the core
of Naboo by increasingly large sea
monsters that eat each other there's
always a bigger fish
at the end of the foundling the armorer
makes a new shoulder pauldron for Boca
tan she asks while forging it if she
should inscribe the Signet of the Night
Owl during the Clone Wars Beau led a
subgroup of Death Watch called the night
owls identifiable by their blue armor
and distinctive visors the faction
continued Fighting For mandalore's
Freedom after Maul took the planet even
battling alongside Ahsoka Tano for a
Time clearly the night owl symbol still
means a lot to Beau her armor is
basically the same in the Mandalorian as
it was in the Clone Wars however she
chooses to inscribe the sign of the
mythosaur on her new pauldron instead
her encounter with the Beast beneath the
Living Waters obviously affected her so
it makes sense that she would want to
wear both icons Boca tan mentions her
father again in the foundling revealing
that he often pushed her to challenge
herself in the ways of combat this
stands in stark contrast to beau's late
sister sateen who was a strict pacifist
that raises the question if Beau was the
one who actually aligned with their
father's ideals why did sateen take the
throne after him
Han shot first isn't quite the rallying
cry among Star Wars fans that it once
was largely because there's just so much
more Star Wars these days arguments over
the changes made in George Lucas's
special editions of the original trilogy
have faded as angry fans simply have a
lot more to complain about now but that
doesn't keep the Mandalorian from
referencing the famous fan debate in the
original cut of A New Hope Han Solo
shoots Greedo dead in the Moss Eisley
Cantina before he can draw his blaster
in the special edition re-release the
footage is edited so that Han's shot is
in response to one of greedos after all
we can't have our hero be a stone cold
killer right thus began the Han shot
first Rebellion among fans in episode 5
of the third season of the Mandalorian
grief carga and pirate king gorion Shard
call back to the spit of Star Wars
history right after the pirate attacks
Navarro he calls grief and accuses him
of murdering one of his men Reef
responds that he shot first which leads
Shard to tell grief that he'll be
shooting first from now on
while speaking to grief cargo via
hologram at the beginning of the pirate
gorian Shard references what's probably
the most popular card game in the Star
Wars Galaxy or at least the outer rim
this isn't sabak you can't Bluff your
way out of this one at the start of the
season when grief and den take out some
of shard's men it's implied that the
high magistrate and the pirate king have
a history it seems that a good portion
of the shared past was spent at the
savak table sabok is most famously
featured in Solo a Star Wars story as
the game through which Han Solo wins the
Millennium Falcon from Lando Calrissian
however that's far from its only Star
Wars appearance the pokerlite game of
which many varieties exist has popped up
in everything from Star Wars Rebels and
the bad batch to the high Republic
novels in fact in the very first episode
of the Mandalorian you can see some
patrons and grief's old Saloon playing
Spock
the new Republic base on Adelphi has
been referenced before in the
Mandalorian and it finally appears in
the pirate though The Outpost Bears all
the fancy iconography of the new
Republic it still feels like a rebel
base Adelphi is a great example of just
how quickly the Rebel Alliance
transformed into a permanent government
a transformation that is still far from
complete in the Mandalorian one shelf on
the wall of The Outpost Cantina has
different models of rebel pilot helmets
seen in the original trilogy the bar
itself has helmets of a different sort
of Stormtroopers and the remains of an
old Imperial probe Droid these seem to
have been hung up as trophies of sorts
which makes sense in this kind of
military base in the season finale
Captain Teva even calls them trophies
the mystery man who briefly speaks with
Captain Teva on the Adelphi base is none
other than Zeb aurelios one of the lead
protagonists of Star Wars Rebels and a
central piece of the ghost crew through
four seasons of the Animated Series Zeb
fought the Empire on every front now it
seems he's been stationed on Adelphi and
is still played by voice actor Steve
Bloom zeb's species the lasat were
actually inspired by some of Ralph
mcqueary's original concept art for
Chewbacca this is just one of the many
instances where Rebels took design cues
from Aquarius unused work if you missed
out on the Animated Series but played
the Star Wars Jedi Fallen Porter video
game you may recognize Zeb as being of
the same species as jaro DePaul
halcastis's original Jedi Master
the pilots bar also sees the return of
three named characters played by behind
the scenes Mandalorian masterminds
sitting next to each other at the bar
are pilots sashketter chip Dodger and
Trapper wolf played respectively by
Deborah Chao Rick FAMU yiwa and Dave
filoni all three have directed episodes
of the series but their impact on the
Star Wars Universe goes well beyond that
family yiwa was made an executive
producer for season three of the
Mandalorian while Chao led the entire
Obi-Wan Kenobi series filoni served as
showrunner for both Star Wars the Clone
Wars and Star Wars Rebels and has been
an executive producer on the Mandalorian
from the start all three have previously
appeared as these characters in The
Mandalorian but this time felony gets to
wear his iconic cowboy hat which is a
nice touch these franchise bigwigs
aren't the only notable guests in the
pirate either Misty Rosas who's played
various roles on the show including the
Frog lady in season 2 plays the
bartender later in the episode
Lieutenant Reed who Teva speaks with
remotely at the very end of the episode
is played by Max Lloyd Jones who was a
body double for Luke Skywalker earlier
in the series
after getting a full episode look at the
new Republic on Coruscant in season
three's third episode Captain Teva
Ventures there for a brief visit in
episode 5. he comes seeking aid for the
pirate besieged Navarro but he's met
only with red tape and excuses some of
this is intentional Sabotage by the
villainous Elia Kane but some of it is
simple bureaucratic incompetence Teva
accuses Colonel Tuttle of acting like an
imperial official but this scene also
evokes the Republic in its final days
during the Clone Wars numerous arcs in
the Animated Series revolve around
neutral planets asking for help and
being ignored by both the Jedi and the
Senate the refusal to send help because
Navarro isn't a member Planet Echoes
these critical failings of the Old
Republic Mandalore in particular
suffered from these kinds of practices
during the Clone Wars Duchess Satine
Crees bogatan's sister refused to join
the Republic's war effort so Mandalore
was left alone to fend off attackers
including the death watch and Darth
Maul's Shadow Collective this neglect
weakened Mandalore before the rise of
the empire viewers know that the new
Republic is eventually devastated by the
first order so these mistakes really
stand out
during din's dogfight with the pirate
snub Fighters there are a couple of
notable callback lines when din first
swoops in and gets on the horn with
brief carga the high magistrate tells
him that he's outnumbered ten to one I
like those odds this calls back to din's
meeting with Verner herzog's client way
back in season one a scene that also
takes place on Navarro when one of the
Stormtroopers tells din they have him
four to one the Mandalorian says the
same line I like those odds later in the
dogfight the duplicitous pirate vein
announces to his comrades I'm on the end
one the line is delivered in a curiously
monotone way for vayne as if it's meant
to elicit memories of Darth Vader's
famous
I'm on the leader from A New Hope the
fact that an N1 Starfighter was the
first ship Anakin Skywalker ever flew
only makes this line feel more
intentional
after clearing Navarro of pirates and
being welcomed as Heroes the
mandalorians decide to finally live out
of the shadows bocatan and the armor of
meat at the covert's old Navarro sewers
Forge and the armor explains how this
much smaller Forge is the same as the
old great Forge of Mandalore because
they share the same purpose this is a
metaphor for bogotan herself who must
now use her experience with the various
Mandalorian groups to unite them while
they aren't directly referenced this
scene evokes bocatan's arcs in both Star
Wars the Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels
Bo Katan has indeed walked in many
different Mandalorian worlds from the
old regime of her father her sister's
pacifist government the death watch the
night owls the Imperial occupation and
finally the way with all this experience
and so many Mandalorian cultures she's
the perfect person to bring all of
mandalore's scattered people together
the armorer asking her to remove her
helmet seems like a big shift and it is
but it also fits she's clearly shaken by
bocatan's vision of the mythosaur and
she now believes that their people are
entering a new age perhaps helmets won't
need to be worn at all times anymore or
at least there may be room for some
diversity of thought
the sixth episode of the third season of
the Mandalorian called guns for hire
opens with a strange encounter on a
quarant ship the vessel is hailed by an
old Imperial cruiser operated by a
mercenary group of mandalorians the same
ship and team that bocatan previously
assembled we learned from the group's
new leader ax wolves that they've been
sent to apprehend the son of a mancala
Viceroy and return him to his family on
Mon calamari apparently the young man
ran away from home to be with his corn
lover in a Romeo and Juliet style Love
Story the long-standing political
tension between the quaran and Mancala
is well documented in Star Wars Canon
it's the primary subject of the Clone
Wars ARC water war and it's been
explored in various other stories as
well the reference to it in guns for
hire doesn't seem to hold any greater
significance other than calling back to
that established conflict while offering
up a little heartbreak in director
Ridley Scott's sci-fi film Blade Runner
protagonist Rick Deckard is tasked with
hunting down Rogue replicants in a neon
tinted Metropolis there are questions
about machine sentience humanity and
what it means to be human in guns for
hire DIN and Boca tan go on a very
similar Mission they hunt down Rogue
droids who have been diverting from
their programming and harming Organics
along the way their Droid prejudices are
called into question and they discover
the hidden Droid culture on plazier 15.
the Super Battle Droid chase scene
through plazier 15's neon Blaze streets
at night feels particularly overt in its
inspiration the set is very similar to
the ones used for the crowded markets
and city streets in Blade Runner much of
the Droid population on plazier 15
consists of old battle droids from the
Confederacy of independent systems who
fought the Republic during the Clone
Wars this makes a bit more sense after
it's revealed that commissioner Hellgate
was and still is part of the separatist
cause The Duchess says that he's served
her family for some time so he may have
begun using old separatist technology
many years ago it's fun to see the Droid
designs in live action again and
especially to hear the base model battle
droids funny voice one more time as in
the Clone Wars The Voice is provided by
sound editor Matthew Wood this is a
restricted area pure to vacate
immediately equally interesting is
hearing someone in the new Republic era
mention Count Dooku by name Hellgate
clearly knew nothing of Dooku's Sith
connections remembering him merely as a
political idealist who fought back
against a corrupt Republic
guns for hire ends with an action-packed
duel between ex-woves and bocatan Creeds
Beau challenges her former subordinate
for the right to command his mercenary
Force which was once hers and she
handily wins the battle is bound to
conjure memories of similar moments from
the Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels in
which Mandalorian honor duels are common
both combatants use a wide range of
weapons and tools at one point ax pulls
out what appears to be a small
vibroblade a tool that several
mandalorians including din himself has
previously used in the Star Wars Legends
timeline vibroblades were even able to
contend with lightsabers though their
power has been subdued in the Disney era
moth Gideon's meeting with the so-called
Shadow council is a treasure Trove of
lore and Star Wars Easter eggs the
council itself was first introduced to
Star Wars canon in the aftermath Trilogy
of novels it was created in secret by
gallius raps a protege of Emperor
Palpatine tasked with ensuring the
Empire's reconstruction in the unknown
regions it was theoretically dissolved
after the battle of jakku and the
official end of the war but it clearly
persists fans will recognize plenty of
the members of the council such as
Captain gilad peleon who was a key
character in author Timothy zahn's
thrawn Trilogy helion is a high-ranking
imperial officer who is thrawn's
right-hand man after the battle of Endor
helion previously made a canonical voice
appearance in Star Wars Rebels as an aid
to thrawn and it seems that he has kept
that role in the unknown region since
also present at the shadow council
meeting is brindle hux father of first
order General turned spy Armitage hux
brindle is played by Brian Gleason the
Young younger brother to Donald Gleason
who plays Armitage in all three Star
Wars sequel films brindle served under
Palpatine during the Imperial era when
he developed the idea of training
Stormtroopers from birth grindel was
also responsible for finding phasma and
bringing her in as an eventual captain
of the first order military his stories
are detailed in many Star Wars books
including the aftermath Trilogy and the
novel phasma and the Mandalorian hux is
associated with a mysterious Imperial
Plan called project Necromancer moth
Gideon makes a comment during the shadow
council meeting that hux is interested
in cloning so this is likely a nod to
Palpatine's eventual return
the spies also features a fun nod to
Classic Cinema when bokeh 10 asks for
volunteers for a recon mission to
Mandalore no one speaks up but after din
Costco Reeves has Vizsla and ax wolves
finally volunteer others begin to follow
a refrain of I will go rings out around
the campfire with one Mandalorian at a
time rising to declare their loyalty and
dedication to a shared cause it seems
pretty clearly meant as a reference to
the famous I am Spartacus scene from
director Stanley Kubrick's Spartacus in
the film when the Romans demand
Spartacus defeated Army turn their
leader in every Soldier proudly declares
himself to be Spartacus to protect the
real one I'm Spartacus I'm Spartacus I'm
Spartacus I'm Spartacus the mandalorians
also have a warrior culture and that
they have a similar sense of Honor so
this homage works well
when the mandalorians finally arrive at
the great Forge of Mandalore they're not
alone MAF Gideon has already erected a
full Imperial base within the boundaries
of the Old Forge likely built years
prior following the Great Purge Gideon
explains his plan to steal the natural
resources of Mandalore to create an even
stronger Dark Trooper model he also
claims to be a superior version of what
the mandalorians had once been the base
itself is full of classic Star Wars
designs from the Thai interceptors and
bombers hanging from the rafters to the
blast doors from the original Death Star
the best car stormtrooper armor first
shown earlier in the episode is on Full
display too there's also a brief glimpse
of what will be revealed as Gideon's
ongoing cloning experiments as he walks
into the meeting with the Shadows
Council he passes by a series of tanks
with humanoid Silhouettes inside his
later reference to the Jedi cloners and
mandalorians all having something of
value and it seems he's something of a
cloner himself in the season finale we
see that these tanks contain potentially
Force sensitive clones of Gideon himself
moth Gideon has a new look in the third
season of the Mandalorian this newest
version of his Darth Vader Halloween
costume is the most complete one yet the
armor is made of best car the Cape is
flowing in an incredibly stylish way and
most importantly he now has a Sith
cosplay helmet to go with the rest of
the outfit Gideon's desire to be seen as
a vader-esque figure has always been
apparent but here it's more obvious than
ever he's also taking inspiration from
the mandalorians themselves to whom he
sees himself as a kind of conqueror his
helmet is most similar to the spiked one
worn by Mandalorian super Commando gar
Saxon at the end of the Clone Wars when
he served Darth Maul and adorned his
armor with red and black paint Gideon
postures like a master villain in his
homemade Vader look but he comes off
like a coward who's always hidden behind
other people's strength that's exactly
what he is after all and the
mandalorians see it clearly he needs the
darksaber to complete his costume and
Boca tan is determined to make sure that
he never gets it
Paz bisla goes down like an absolute
champ at the end of the spies taking
down the whole platoon of best car
Stormtroopers and saving almost the
entire Recon team before being taken out
by members of the praetorian Guard it's
a heroic death for a minor character
who's gotten a lot of strong development
in season three and there's zero shame
in losing to the foes who bring him down
in his earlier meeting with the shadow
Council moth Gideon requests three
members of the elite praetorian guard
the same fearsome fighters who later
protect supreme leader snoke of the
first order and ultimately perish at the
hands of Rey and kylo ren the three who
pop up on Mandalore have the same deadly
weapons and striking red armor as they
do in the Last Jedi has may have had a
shot against them at the beginning of
the fight but by the time they show up
to take him out he's nearly depleted
the Mandalorian season 3 finale the
return is basically one giant extended
action sequence and since it's set in a
secret Imperial base it's the perfect
venue for some callbacks to the original
Star Wars specifically the battle and
Gideon's headquarters pays homage to the
Death Star scenes from A New Hope
watching DIN and grogu sneak around
corridors is bound to conjure images of
Old Ben Kenobi doing the same all
Imperial facilities look similar due to
the requirements of fascist Chic but the
specific pacing of the sequence is
particularly evocative the similarities
only grow once din confronts Gideon
himself their battle plays out a bit
differently than Darth Vader's last duel
with Obi-Wan but the illusion still
plays by the end the episode also
includes some nods to the second to
death star's destruction in Return of
the Jedi axwoves crashes the
mandalorian's stolen Imperial cruiser
into Gideon's base mirroring the
executor being driven into the Death
Star too
after spending most of the Mandalorian
season 3 on the sidelines r5d4 comes in
clutch during the season finale via
calmlink din tells him to skomp into the
base to help out unless you've played
Star Wars Jedi Fallen order you may not
know that the multi-purpose hacking tool
used by R2D2 and other Astromech droids
is called a scomp link R5 uses his to
infiltrate the base's Mainframe thus
triggering yet another reference to a
New Hope din calling out orders to R5
while navigating the basis defenses is
sure to feel familiar it's the exact
same situation in which Luke Skywalker
and R2 find themselves while saving
Princess Leia from the Death Star the
moment when din is trapped in the energy
Fields is particularly evocative as it
directly mirrors the iconic trash
compactor scene and just like R2 R5
comes through and helps Our Heroes
succeed
the best guard clad Stormtroopers who
guard moff Gideon's base aren't your
average Imperial grunts in addition to
their shiny new armor they're armed with
a wider and more deadly range of weapons
while these best guard Troopers are new
to Star Wars in the Mandalorian season 3
they seem to have taken some cues from
The Purge Troopers in Star Wars Jedi
Fallen order din's hallway fight to
Gideon's Command Center is basically a
video game mini boss battle with each
energy field revealing slightly
different foes some of the Troopers
wield riot shields and Electro batons
which are used by many of The Purge
Troopers in Fallen order din makes use
of these tools himself to make short
work of them though things get a bit
trickier when he confronts Gideon and
the elite praetorian guard in lieu of a
lightsaber Gideon also has a purge
Trooper weapon a full electrostaff prior
to the rise of the empire electrostabs
were also used by the Magna guards who
made up General Grievous personal
Entourage
grogu really shows off in the
Mandalorian season 3 finale he holds off
three praetorian guards by himself for
an impressive amount of time in a scene
that Echoes the throne room battle in
The Last Jedi he plays a key role in
their defeat and he even has some
non-force related highlights like
spraying din with back to spray from
ig-12 that moment calls back to the
season one finale in which ig-11 helps
heal den and it isn't the only scene
that does so grogu's big moment at the
end of season 3 isn't a force push or a
clever attack but an act of protection
as ax wolves crashes the Mandalorian
Cruiser into Gideon's base rogu uses all
of his power to create a barrier around
himself DIN and vocatan shielding them
from the Flames this is the exact same
move he uses in the season 1 finale to
save din Reef carga and Cara Dune from a
flame Trooper the difference of course
is the scale
denjarin has acted as grogu's father for
most of the Mandalorian but in the
season 3 finale that relationship
finally becomes official din asks the
armorer to acknowledge grogu as his
apprentice and a foundling no longer
when she refuses on the grounds that he
is too young to speak the Creed and
therefore requires parental permission
din declares that he will adopt the
little guy the armorer then dubs him din
grogu what's arguably even more
interesting here is the armorer's brief
reference to din's Mandalorian Youth and
apprenticeship just as your teacher did
for you so who was Den's teacher the way
the scene is set and the particular
delivery of the line implies it might
have been the armorer herself that would
make sense given the close relationship
the two share and it would add an
interesting extra layer to their Dynamic
of course this could also be setting up
something else in the Mandalorian season
4. perhaps din's time as grogu's teacher
will lead to flashbacks to his own youth
after vanquishing MAF Gideon and his
forces the mandalorians begin the long
process of restoring their Homeworld to
its former glory they begin with two of
the planet's most sacred sites The
Living Waters where Ragnar Vizsla
finally speaks the Creed and the great
Forge which is lit for the first time in
decades there's also another view of the
old capital city of sundari where
bocatan's sister sateen once ruled it's
little more than Rubble but with plant
life returning and the mandalorians
ready to rebuild it could be great and
proud once again this isn't just
momentous for fans of the Mandalorian
but for Star Wars Rebels and the Clone
Wars followers too Boca Tan's story on
the modern Saga of Mandalore have been
going since before Disney took over the
franchise at the great Forge axwolves
leads the other mandalorians an
inappropriate chant
in the past the phrase has been used as
a Battle Cry it's even shouted by the
villainous Death Watch in the Clone Wars
but here it's more of a declaration of
Peace the Clans have reunited and the
planet has been reclaimed now at last
the mandalorians can build for the
future
[Music]